hello
and i think i'm live
and here i go
being live oh wow what a blast
so uh
first topic of discussion
today is
hans must be trying to find a good wi-fi
signal in the van it's tough out there
i'm actually in front of my buddy
riley's house and he's just hanging out
inside probably being a little bit sad
he's probably sad right now but i'm in
here in the van doing a little podcast
deepu
uh talking about anything and everything
some guy was like oh is there gonna be a
girl in the van
no girls in the van yet oh listen to
that it's a little jittery
um
what are you high on this is the common
question
that i get a lot is
uh what am i high on i'm actually
completely sober right now so it's funny
that you would assume that i'm on drugs
because i'm just so psychedelic all the
time
um
i uh my left ear loves this oh really
that's funny hahaha it's weird because
it's like a [ __ ] thing like i'm doing
instagram live and youtube live
okay there's a jittery thing so i'm
plugged in onto youtube but i'm not
plugged in interior we see your eyes
okay this is help
this is a fan favorite people love it
when i do this
um yeah i mean i'm just going live
and it's fun
uh do you celebrate thanksgiving yeah i
mean free food i'll celebrate anything
really
i got the fan on maybe i'll turn the fan
off it's a little bit loud
and tomorrow is thanksgiving
happy happy thanksgiving to everyone
thanksgiving is a great time uh hey hans
looking good bud thanks man
everything that i look good
uh john williams i always love it when
people tell me i look good
um happy thanksgiving i'm not high right
now
i was thinking about getting high but
probably after the podcast or slash the
live because i don't want to get banned
or demonetized
one what's up brother just after 45
seconds for the commercials to see what
you got let me hear 30 seconds of why
white people think they run the world
thank you brother
thank you for watching the commercials
you know it's hopefully muted it or like
you know clipped your nails all this
happening but i think white people think
they run the world because they do
economically
and because they put in a lot of hard
work a lot of genocide a lot of
backbreaking genocide went into them
running the world do you remember which
specific point which you decided that
you were going to do comedy yeah
uh right after listening to joe rogan i
was living in chattanooga working at a
startup company for a medical device
company
and uh
the thing about the medical device
company was that i was getting paid
minimum wage living in a house that this
guy bought and it's like a very
like a slave labor but it's like
understandable slave labor
and
it was just like
wow
this life is not fulfilling what else is
out there let me do what joe rogan said
and do comedy and so i went to a comedy
open mic and then i started doing comedy
and then it was just like so great
and i had a great time and it's like
more fulfilling and stuff
um
let's see
i did van life for a while this past
summer drive right across canada slowly
some of the best times i've had so far
in my life the thing about van life is
that you don't need a hotel you can stop
wherever you want you can sleep whenever
you want it's just very very freedom
inducing and it's not like traveling any
other place
it's uh very different
uh because you get to have freedom and
you get to sleep whenever you want and
it's just like you don't have to pack
um
you
can go wherever you want and stuff it's
just
the better way to go my opinion
um
i'm trying to find a white
white
background oh this is white enough
hopefully this is good lighting
makes me look a little bit pale
um the instagram looks better than the
video camera does
um
come to salt lake city if you get a
chance i would love to thank you man
that was hella funny
wow
thanks man
uh i like being funny
it's my bread and butter whenever i feel
funny it's like it's like cha-ching
i'm a comedian i need to be funny all
the time but it's like weird because i'm
not really funny all the time it's a
paradox hans kim liked man but that's
what jesus said
okay vinnie donuts
you're banned
for
life
i am actually not gay um
i mean maybe gatum is the future but i
am two 90s for being gay what the [ __ ]
is with the sixth street blues episodes
can't find them on your channel it jumps
from like episode three to ten
um the numbering convention is sort of a
joke that i do maybe sometimes it's not
accurate i didn't think that we did a
lot though i think i think we did four
so maybe you're right yeah maybe
it's like uh that practical prank
where you have goats labeled two and
three
and then there's one and then they're
looking for another one but there's just
one kyle rittenhouse not guilty
not guilty not guilty i support any
murder
have you ever heard had acupuncture yes
i have by this woman that i was sort of
trying to bang i don't really believe it
worked but she came into the van and did
it for free
and then there was like this moment
where i thought like we could kiss
but i i was like
i'm gonna open the door but it's taking
a long time so it's like maybe she'll
turn around and kiss me but then she did
it so i was like okay [ __ ] it i just
opened the door i mean i wasn't gonna
kidnap her but i did not i don't know
uh
i wasn't trying to
you know non-consensually do anything
well asians are not good with technology
are you funnier than
that's not a question that i like to
ponder hans do you believe in ufos and
aliens not really i don't think it's
worth the time how old are you 32 hey
from ireland come visit us in maine
me
miss strawberry you just left some
random stick you in the nozzle she was a
comedian open your eyes hans can we get
a katan live stream i would love to do a
katan live stream
uh katana is a little bit difficult
right now because uh
riley's being sad a lot recently
but um
i might uh find another patron to
do katan with um
hans came like man but that's what jesus
ah this
is from a long time ago
oh my god
let me know
um
so what did you think of the aubry
verdict
mod arbory whenever i hear a mod i think
i saw in a mod and i'm like oh that
guy's funny but then it's like no it's
the dead guy
um a mod arbory verdict i think he was
murder
you definitely shouldn't be running up
on black people jogging and accusing
them of crimes
um especially if they didn't do it it's
like a big no-no
i mean we've all been there we've all
been afraid of black people
because uh sometimes they can be scary
but it's like most of us don't murder
them so like try not to murder black
people
it's a really sensitive time and also
like murdering it's not a good feeling
like what are you doing why are you
on the [ __ ] with a shotgun running
around confronting people it's like call
the cops let them do it i mean it's
they're not that much better with not
murdering people but it's like
they want to be that's like they feel
good doing that they're bored they want
to go do something they're like hey that
guy looks like he's [ __ ] whatever
let's go [ __ ] confront him and stuff
um
murder is very very bad for you you know
it makes you feel really bad and it's
like did i really should i have done
that and then it's like is there any
other way i could have done it
uh
anyone else hearing that noise
uh is this in the world unfortunately
well he was an ex-cop that makes sense
um i mean i just don't think that it's a
good uh good thing to do and it's like
sad because these people have their
lives ruined but i mean i guess they
deserve it because they've ended another
guy's life but it's like
i don't have faith in the american
justice system to be like
oh we're going to rehabilitate you we're
going to fix you up we're going to make
you better it's not going to be a just
punishment they're just going to [ __ ]
throw him away and forget about him so i
don't know i wish they were
rehabilitated and maybe they had to like
go watch a medea movie for like
every day for like a week and then
write a book report on it or like maybe
they would have to like talk to you know
like
uh eddie murphy or like
you know a funny guy and
just get roasted they should just get
roasted they should have a comedy
central roast
um i don't know how to fix them
someone misses my glasses my glasses are
too far away right now did you hear
brian laundry killed his gf's murderer
is that what happened someone they were
getting into a lot of fights and then
someone else murdered her and he was
like you [ __ ] how dare you
kill the girl that i was arguing with a
lot
um stop stealing wi-fi from the
mcdonald's parking lot that's actually
where i edited the last uh six street
blues
um right now i'm using riley's wi-fi
slash mikey biggs and everyone
only
they need a headbutting a bullet i mean
that's funny thing to say
might have a loose connection when are
you going on jre oh i'll just go on let
me just text joe rogan real quick get on
jre
you know hey joe rogan can i please come
to your podcast
thanks bye kkk
okay
why do you say like so much because i'm
an american and i aspire to be a valley
girl
and i love
i love uh thinking and that's how i
think that's how i say uh
jihad why did you stop pursuing
mechanical engineering what just
illusioned you probably 12 years 16
years of sitting in a chair all day then
i was like oh there's going to be more
chair sitting i'm going to be a
professional chair sitter in the future
let me not do that do you believe
chronic masturbation can lead to
parkinson's disease
i mean parkinson's is like a
neurological thing i don't think that
jerking your dick off is gonna i think
jerking
your dick off is good for your brain
just like put you in a good chemical
state
like that's like a good state to be in
just pleasurable comfort
are you going to be on
love on the spectrum
that's a good show for me you know i'm
uh
i could be the king of the autistics or
a nerd
shout out from hawaii aloha hans
hey
hey ping dang how do you start to write
a joke what's the process so what i do
which i don't recommend
i hate that
i might need to get a new zoom i might
need to buy a zoom on amazon and then
return my old broken zoom
which is what i plug my mic into how do
i write a joke
i write a joke like this
i
see something that i want to write about
and i'm like oh this is so annoying why
is this happening things are so wrong we
should have a more equal distribution of
wealth just giving all our money to one
person who's really rich is not a good
way to organize society and it's kind of
weak that you think that you need a rich
person to tell you how to live your life
we should have a more democratic
approach to society and then i keep
writing stuff like that until eventually
i write something funny and i'm like oh
maybe i could write that
as a thing
um i feel special to be able to talk to
you
you're not that special a lot of people
talk to me
and a lot of people abuse that privilege
and
just talk talk talk oh people i met this
one guy yesterday who's just like
he's just saying nothing he just wants
to take up your time it's just like a
game of like time taking up for him just
the more time i can take up the better
it's like how much [ __ ] can i say
uh
to keep people
captivated
while seeing nothing it's a terrible
terrible way to talk the camera quality
makes you look more korean thank you i'm
sure that was a compliment
koreans are pretty cool they have big
heads big faces it's good to have a
small head in korea come to belgium just
right bring the camera and you'll blend
right in with all our japanese tourists
belgium sounds lovely i would love to go
to belgium
um i hope that i can go
uh
you know belgium who gives a [ __ ]
so i stopped doing my project for you
thank you for stopping your project
where can i send a shirt from my brand
um please message me on instagram and
i'll send you the address of riley's
house
it's no risk for me do you go to barbara
cut your own hair i'm going to cut my
own hair i forgot i was going to do that
today i learned how to do it
on youtube i don't want to save 20 bucks
every month so it's a
thing that happens forever
um
chicago to austin taking the risk
because of you bro appreciate it oh
why why are you taking the risk for me
what am i gonna do for that
for you i don't know what you expect
from me but please come it's a great
place i think um
i think uh
austin's a great city for comedy right
now not only is it have a lot of open
mics
and shows and some of the best comedians
in the world it also has an energy that
cannot be replicated anywhere else
because there is hope and vigor and
happiness
in austin right now
there is a
festival energy a frat energy an energy
of funness and career fulfillment in one
any time we're having fun it's also
socializing with people who might take
off and make a big next week so it's
just such a good time it's crazy being
here and you can have fun other places
but you'll have that empty sort of
shallow fun where you're like oh i
shouldn't be having this but here when
you're having fun you're making
connections and you're
talking to people who have hope and
desires and
uh thing they think that it can be the
future so that's cool
uh if you
keep up writing you've gotta sing about
tony
the best thing about tony is that he is
a long-term thinker he's like
thinking three seven eighteen steps
ahead
and a lot of people
are just stuck just in the moment just
unable to
see the larger picture and tony is very
good at larger picture thinking and like
he's
he's doing things that i don't even know
uh
the end results of like he's he's doing
making moves and doing things that
are
out of my comprehension right now
because he's in the game for so long and
he's understands
um
the game better than i do whose face is
longer yours are tony's
uh i think i have a bigger head
i mean not a bigger head like a
i don't know it's hard to tell
uh i think i have a longer face
um
but i might get surgery so
to make my face smaller
you have a mic set up in the van yep
that's what you're listening to
what's the worst thing about tony
uh i guess the way that he physically
abuses me but it's funny sometimes the
guessing i've seen tony do is
um
[Music]
like ask me to suck his dick or
something but i think it was a
joke uh i am high as [ __ ] thank you for
telling me i almost didn't realize i was
high as [ __ ] because i haven't smoked
any weed or drank any drinks tonight
uh but as long as you think i'm high as
[ __ ] i guess i am i wish
i wish i could be high on this drug all
the time this is a free drug just have
yo-yo-yos i'll tell you that you're high
on drugs
thanks yeah i'm totally high now that
you said i'm high i wish that's how
highness worked i wish i was hired
that's a joke that i do it means in
korean
excuse me where is the post office or
more literally excuse me post office is
where
um
how are you dating someone right now no
i'm not dating anyone please if you are
looking for a date i am available
i am hanging out with this beautiful
lady who is not
really wanting to do anything with me
physically which is fine i guess
but uh i am looking to do things
physically with people it's tough
hanging out with someone who's not
willing to do anything physical with you
because you know that there's gonna be
someone who wants to she's gonna want
and then it's like i'm just hanging out
with her being a dutiful little friend
and then eventually she's gonna find
someone who's like oh my god you're so
funny
oh yeah you can totally finger me and
it's like what the [ __ ] i've just been
sitting here for five days just carrying
your hand back okay honey uh go ahead
and get fingered i'll just watch your
drink room here
it's like it's not a great position to
be in for anyone so it's like maybe
it's not something that we should do
maybe we should [ __ ] more i think we
should [ __ ] more and i think there's a
lack of [ __ ] which is very sad
um
i think that uh women are very afraid
and maybe it's because men keep raping
them
so maybe we should stop raping them and
they'll [ __ ] more
uh that's my strategy
um but yeah i mean men want to [ __ ]
women
are give or take on it so it's like
uh we need to we need to make sure that
women feel comfortable enough to [ __ ]
maybe they'll [ __ ] me
but uh yeah i mean
what is with [ __ ] like shouldn't we
do it a lot as much as possible
um i think then the world would be a
better place and we could have like true
utopia if we could just [ __ ] all the
time
um
what else [ __ ] her presentary style
jesus christ
like i said before on the stream podcast
live love podcast youtube uh murder is
very bad for you it's so bad for you
it's like makes you feel terrible it's
like imagine like if you like run into
someone's car except like 10 times worse
that's what murder is like
i uh i don't like feeling guilty
um
how's it feel opening for joe again
wants to come crazy your beard is
looking hella thick today
um i wish i was at a parade in wisconsin
okay i'll try to be more entertaining um
my
how does it feel it feels like this
oh my god whoa
whoa
feels like that
it's like the [ __ ] best thing that
could happen to me you speak on murder
like someone with experience care to
share yes in 1992
i murdered a person with in cold blood i
hate
did him and then i murdered him i think
i have experience with murder because
i've dreamed of it
and also because i've like done terrible
things to people and then it's like oh
damn that felt bad i guess murder is
worse than this
or maybe because of my psychedelic
experiences i thought i murdered people
but i have never murdered people
i'm oh fro my kill to death ratio is
at an infinite
infinity
um
the
thing about
um
the thing about um
oh my god
the thing about uh
joe opening for joe rogan is that is the
pinnacle of everything that i wanted to
do in comedy
and also just like do headlining spots
and stuff
but
it's like the guy that i started with
and or started because of and it's uh
he's like a guy that i really respect
and i think he's one of the best
comedians in history so it's amazing to
get to open for him and i hope that i
can
tell my children that i opened for him
you know when i moved to austin
hopefully from crypto money shall i buy
a new van like the one from meet the
[ __ ] and i can move into the glove
compartment indefinitely
i think that if you're in fact investing
in cryptocurrency that you should
definitely move into a van because
that's very
uh unstable unless it's bitcoin i don't
know i don't know about cryptocurrency i
think that it's a good idea and i think
that uh
maybe
it's
good to do but the speculation on it i
don't think is the
ultimate form of cryptocurrency i think
speculating on cryptocurrency is like
i don't know
i think it might make you rich but it's
not something that everyone can do i
think we should just have like a [ __ ]
we should adopt it already
as a policy but i don't know just
betting on which one you think is going
to be the one to make it is
kind of seems like a waste of time
um so
a lot of people
on instagram are like add me they're
like you're boring i can improve this by
yelling or like talking about something
else
just sucks a stand-up i know i know that
some people don't respect a stand-up
comedy but i do so much i think that he
goes for larger topics and he like
acts out in the boston style he has a
lot of energy and he like talks about
things that are actually interesting to
me and that are like the ultimate
culmination of stand-up comedy instead
of just talking about dick jokes he gets
like the end of why you're talking about
dick jokes and he like does the meta
comedy very well
and i don't think that a lot of people
appreciate it because they just
don't think that
he's uh
he's like a professor so they don't take
what he has to say seriously
you ever receive a rim jaw
job
i don't know what that means um
uh what's your thanksgiving plans i have
no thanksgiving plans
uh my friend invited me to his place uh
gareth invited me
i might go to his thing or i might just
stay here and chill out and relax and
have a good time here
it really depends
um
is
the decentraland is full of insults
um i am involuntarily celibate i wish i
wasn't celibate but i am so it's not a
big deal
um come to my house do you want to poof
some acid
boof like take it up the ass
uh brendan schaab
i think brendan schaub is newer at
comedy i mean not at joe rogan's level
obviously um i'm sure that he does well
i mean like there's lots of people who
get into comedy through different
means
and he has a big following
so i mean he's successful in that way
but i think like
um
his last special i heard wasn't that
good he's trying to make enough on
youtube and stand up that's what i'm
trying to do i got like
i don't know if it's gauche or rude or
inconsiderate to say but i'm gonna say
it anyways
but i made like 650
in
last month from youtube so that's enough
to get an apartment in austin
so if i can keep doing that then i can
move into an apartment and have like a
permanent podcast studio but maybe
people like the novelty of me podcasting
from the van
so i don't know i don't know what i'm
going to do
um
it's really up in the air at this point
uh
i'm at 63 percent
well battery life is very good even
though i'm live
anyways uh so maybe i can make more
money and then i could live in a thing i
do have a patreon hans kim patreon on
google
um i don't
like doing the thing
yeah i might get an apartment and just
keep podcasting from the van and just
not tell anyone that i have an apartment
just go home every night sleep in a
apartment and then be like oh man van
life is so hard not a boy keep the van
and let me rent it when i come back down
there
yeah i mean i could have people live in
my van
i could uh
make an airbnb
tell us a joke if you really are a
comedian
um so here's a joke what's the deal with
women not having sex with me isn't that
kind of sad
patreon follows this attract yeah i
pretend you're poor yeah i'm pretty rich
right now the pandemic really helped me
out i got a lot of money from washington
state and it really set me on a good
path
to texas and uh i quarantined for as
long as i could but then i was like if
no one's doing it why am i doing it
i mean i'm just going to be quarantining
for longer now so let me just go to a
place where
i don't care if people get coronavirus
from me texas because they obviously
don't give a [ __ ] about it here so
let me go to a place where i don't have
to feel bad if i spread coronavirus and
go do whatever i want go out every night
and have a good time
where's your girlfriend of the week
i have not had a girlfriend um
my last
girl that i was seeing got really mad
i suggested that we were dating and it's
like well i know it's like [ __ ]
elementary school we're not dating we're
only seeing each other it's not a big
deal don't say we're dating because
we're not dating i mean women are very
like into being exclusive and they're
like oh the more men i can reject from
having sex with me the better of a
person i am he is one of the biggest
upping upcoming comedians in the world
oh thank you for saying that i don't
feel it at all i'm still doing
the shows that i do and practicing my
craft and like going up on stage and
bombing by
yelling at conservative open micros
about how they're wrong i love it
because in texas there's so many
conservative open mikers and i just get
to go up there and tell them that their
beliefs are stupid and that they should
change their ways and it's just fun
because i'm very
very not
not conservative at all
hans
i have a hair loss i need a new pay for
my ssi i live in washington any advice
i don't know i don't know about
washington
whatever
uh i
live that your love on youtube
what is the worst heckle you got here's
a heckle story so
i was performing at the grizzly pair and
it was a show that if you know the
grizzly pair it's like ratchet as [ __ ]
it's like
very haphazard
and the host was not really policing the
room he was just letting this lesbian
couple heckle
they're like boo
i hate you
and they were just like participating in
every comedian set and every comedian
would have to go up there and deal with
this heckling and then the host would be
like
yes keep doing your heckling we like
that that's a good thing and then i went
up there and i was like hey i'm the
alpha male i'm [ __ ] awesome what's up
with you guys you guys are a bunch of
idiots because i'm really really cool
and it was like a bit that i'm doing
where i pretend like i'm arrogant and
then this person got really mad at me
and then i was like can you stop
heckling and he's like now i like
echoing and i was like i don't approve
of your lifestyle because
even though she was a lesbian and uh
that's like a really triggering phrase
for them and then she threw a cup of
alcohol at me
and then i i just stood there and took
him what that doesn't hurt
you only hurt my feelings
and then she threw another one at me
and then
she walked right across the stage and i
was like what
and then she was like
and then
yeah i got hit with two cups of alcohol
and then i finished my set doing my set
in like a very shaky voice
but i finished it and it was it was fine
and then afterwards the host was like
man you really [ __ ] up man
you got an audience member to throw a
drink at you that's your fault not the
audience member who's been heckling all
night's fault it's your fault she's just
over there a food or a some cookie shop
right now and having the time of her
life i was like [ __ ] you gotta police
your [ __ ] room you bitch-ass host
and anyways i'm doing way better than he
is right now and he acted like i was an
idiot but it's really her fault hans
should have been in the new american pie
movie can i have a kiss hi papa j s
depends on your genital configuration
what do you think of tony hawk always
wanted to be the joker obsessing over it
then letting
go of the ban and now jeremiah's the
voice of the joker
series i don't give a [ __ ] i don't think
he gives a [ __ ]
i mean if he wants to animate the voice
of the joker he could do it in a
heartbeat i don't think it's a really
big deal i'm sorry if i missed it what's
your favorite joke thanks your favorite
joke that you tell if you have one my
favorite joke that i tell is a mitch
hedberg joke
tell me about the federal reserve i
don't really know much about the federal
reserve
i don't think that's a real problem i
mean
i think it's the corporate people who
own the whatever
name of your first special are you
trying to put mark hamill out of a job
yes i am the joker
when i am the joker i shall rule the
world it's so easy to do the joker voice
why does everyone want to be the joker
the joker is such a big part of our
culture because that's how we feel we
feel evil with no
hope of uh
fixing our society so we just want to be
crazy crazy wild and schizophrenic
and that's what uh we are like we're
[ __ ] jokers it's [ __ ] sad
what was it like planning and
coordinating the september 11th attacks
it was explosive and a
building burner and
that was the worst attempt at the joker
voice hans lo what the [ __ ]
yeah i'm not like you people i don't
want to be the joker that's not my
[ __ ]
that's not my [ __ ] goal in life i
don't want to just be an agent of chaos
i know that's your ultimate [ __ ]
dream because you have no hope for
humanity but
there's a lot more to people than just
being crazy and chaotic
um i think it's really funny
do you make karbi kaibichim in your van
nope i cook a lot of meat i just cook
straight up meat and then i eat it with
samjhang i need to do it in or whatever
um
do you ever get offended when people
joke about the holocaust since your
grandparents are survivors that's just a
reference to joke but um
i don't get offended i think like it's
good that we're normalizing the
holocaust and just like having it be an
accepted part of our culture and being
like oh look at this horrible thing that
happened and i think it's good that
there's a horrible thing that we can
refer to to put into context everything
else that happens
in our society
were you funny when you first started
out or did it take time
i mean i thought i was funny um but my
first set is online on youtube so you
can check it out i had some uh good
ideas very nervously said and kind of
bad timing but
people in the scene in seattle didn't
like me when i first started out and i
think that had more to do with them than
it did with me because they do a lot of
weak comedy where they're like oh you
like me because i'm your friend right so
this is funny because you know me kind
of jokes
and i was doing more like
jokes that you could do in front of like
a real audience and jokes that refer to
the world that we live in instead of the
tiny little clique subculture that we're
in
um what does offend you
what offends me is normalizing
conservatism and
acting like that human beings the best
of human beings is what we see now
because i think human beings can do a
lot better than what we're doing now
we're just seeing human beings
struggling
and that's
that's what we think human experience is
like
but this is just what human beings are
like when you give them five percent of
the gdp if we have more of the gdp i
think you see a lot better side of human
beings
what do you use on your hair uh nothing
i haven't showered in a week
maybe two
um starcraft diablo starcraft i am a
starcraft 2 master league player once
i'm probably platinum right now
if i practice i could be good who is
your favorite comedian mitch hedberg
comes to mind joe rogan comes to mind
but steve martin
i love how he was doing metacomedy
before it was [ __ ]
a thing he was doing meta stand-up
comedy before stand-up even took off do
you miss kissing girl everyone killed
tony it's been a dry streak and i feel
for you i do kind of miss kissing girls
on kill tony but it's it was such a big
distraction like people were like just
talking about that
but i mean also people really liked it
some of them like whenever that was
those are my most popular posts on
instagram so like people who are my fans
liked it
but people who
are just like tolerating me
they didn't really like it
i think that uh kissing girls is really
fun and i think that we should live in a
more sex positive culture
and i think that a lot of people
uh are afraid of sex and i
i like to think that i did my part in
destigmatizing sex and having it be like
more of a thing that we all do like if i
could get a kiss you can get a kiss we
can all get kisses
kisses are plentiful we have it with
each other and we can share it
uh and
um
we should we should kissing is good and
it makes people feel good and we just
want to uh
love each other and that's possible we
should love each other more and kisses
help in that regard
um
i do miss kissing people i want to kiss
people but it's like i also enjoy just
doing comedy and just
uh you know i felt like when i first
became a regular i wanted to have
something like people could [ __ ]
latch onto and like have my thing and
make my impact because otherwise i felt
like i was a little boring like i was
just up there talking and now that i'm
not kissing people they're like oh thank
god he's not kissing people yeah just
talk they're like okay what is he saying
and then they have to listen to me it's
like something that
it's a hook so i don't know it just sort
of happened it's not like i [ __ ] did
anything to make it happen it was all
tony so
uh all i did was uh say yes to the dress
what is your opinion on the first
amendment i think is a great amendment
and i think there's a lot of countries
that don't have free speech that could
use it
um
[Music]
uh free speech yeah do nazis deserve to
talk yes and uh
the only problem with that is that we
should live in a country where those
people aren't created but we don't have
the economic condition
to
create healthy people who are
intellectually savvy so they're falling
victim to
uh shitty ideas and then with free
speech you get to see it you get to see
how broken people are
and that's kind of cool
um
does your passport still expire if you
leave it in the fridge
that's funny
it's assuming that passports are like
food
and uh
you keep food from expiring
um
which i think is a british more british
term
uh by keeping in the fridge they're like
oh what if other things don't expire
hans are you making any comedy sketches
right now uh no not currently i should i
want to do another six street blues you
have an answer showered in two weeks
that's why that chick won't bang you bro
i mean i don't have that gene that
creates body odor
um but i don't think that
just because i shower chicks will want
to [ __ ] me because all of you guys
shower and none of you guys are getting
laid i used to do drugs i still do but i
used to too i don't think economics has
any to the people having shitty ideas oh
well that's where we disagree i think
that if you make people poor they're
like [ __ ] i need an outlet for this but
if they're like happy and fed they're
like ah what a relaxing setting like if
you go to a school and you deprive half
the children of food and make them
struggle in the ghetto and projects
they're going to have a harder time
learning than kids who live in the
suburbs and relax by the pool and then
mosey on down to their tutor whenever
they feel like it i think
having a relaxed mind and not having to
struggle to survive and be uh
animals makes you better at uh learning
do you think women would stop using
abortion jokes to make it seem like
they're not dull
uh
should
should they stop using abortion jokes
to stop to me i don't know
women are like oh my god i'm so unique
and special because i
have a no abortion well
abortion wow i think that if abortion
was normalized and legalized instead of
fighting over it every [ __ ] 10 years
that maybe it wouldn't be so shocking
and that they would just
have to talk about something real
um how did you find your voice on
stagware
on stage
i found my voice by being like what do i
want to talk about what do i want the
world to be like what do i want to see
change and then i tried to implement
that into my
stand-up comedy or subtly hint at it
like i have very strong opinions on
kovid but
i found that most of the jokes that i
wrote on it aren't funny but if i like
subtly hint at it at the iceberg the tip
of the iceberg that is my feelings on uh
coronavirus response in america and
eight hundred thousand dead instead of
just being like you guys are evil you
guys are the worst if i just like yeah
thank you guys for
you know letting the coronavirus spread
then it's funnier now hold on a minute
purple or green to hell with purple
people unless they're cooking
are you in the van yes i'm in the van we
used to get 30 days of christmas on tv
like count doesn't even know i got 30
days of trials
yeah it's trial time there's two big
trials happening at the same time wow
what a time we live in
uh ahmad arbury
happened
i think before kyle rittenhouse and
their trials were at the same time um
is austin somehow dangerous
it is
dangerous and
that there's a lot of shootings
happening on sixth street
um
i think that if uh
if we had more economically favorable
conditions people wouldn't have to shoot
each other to feel good about themselves
who was your favorite stand-up mitch
hedberg
or joe rogan or steve martin can you
make your elbows touch
my back you want to see my tits
hell yeah trevor let's get this guy in
yuck yucks
winkle in your kitchen sinkhole deleted
his message i want to know what he said
now
they'll take you down if you use the c
word really
they do that can i say the n word
the c word isn't even that bad
are you sure that they'll take down my
stream if i say [ __ ]
because i feel like content is fine what
if i'm australian
um how much have you donated to jazlane
maxwell's defense fund
i mean
is it really that bad of a thing to hook
girls up with rich men
i mean as long as they're over 18.
do you know esther coo i know ever i
don't know how i found her but i've been
i've been following her forever you high
no i'm not high
i'm not high i wish i was but i'm taking
a break of smoking because my throat is
really sensitive
happy thanksgiving thank you corey thank
you armchair man cracker don't spend
this toonie all in one place hans a
toonie
canadians
i feel like a stripper
and strip in uh canada the strippers
make better money because they're uh
dollar bills or whatever higher or
something
when was the last time you were tested
for gonorrhea probably like october last
year
uh when was the last time
live from the van yes hans women learned
to listen to hans yet
yes
unkilled tony
sometimes they listen
uh i feel like a hog that han's brought
back to his van a hog
the ladies that i date are not hogs
they're wart
they're not warthogs they're a beautiful
beautiful cows
what does your angry face look like you
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
you goddamn cracker you think you
mexican [ __ ] can [ __ ] with me
i live in a van [ __ ]
i'm pooping right now says shimazube
i want to see kell tony live but i'm in
ohio if only they had planes trains or
automobiles that went from ohio to texas
i mean honestly
if you bought a plane ticket it would
cost like 100 bucks from ohio plus
uh the ticket it's like 50 bucks plus
hotel it's like 50 bucks 200 bucks you
can't you can't manage 200 bucks
i mean i don't know if you have that
kind of money but you know maybe you
should try
i look perpetually high maybe it's
because i smoked so much weed
red rosey i've only been to yellow rose
um i should go i've only been there once
uh so here's another topic of
conversation
um
drugs
are they good or bad i think that drugs
are coping mechanism for a society that
is aimless and listless and just
floating in the river and we're not
really doing it not floating in a lake
and we're not really doing anything so
you might as well get high is it worth
it to go to kill tony yes it is the best
comedy show ever
uh it's fresh every week and it's the
energy in there is just electric and
it's packed no all the time
your face is adorable thanks timothy
elliot you spending thanksgiving alone
probably
i might stream during thanksgiving might
as well what's up hans i love your
comedy my dude thanks man you're cray oh
i never thought about that i guess i'm a
little crazy
what would your drug dealer name be
yo i'm little fez
i got a little fez on and i'm sending
you drugs
live video pause reconnecting
um you should date that north korean
shake
the girl that's always crying at the u.n
it is very sad what is happening in
north korea oh i'm so sad
yeah baby it is pretty sad now why don't
you suck on my
south korean dick
it was a rudest get tony
well i i i love don marrero but he did
say i had a long way to go
which is he's not wrong but i don't
think that was rude i think he was just
uh
high or something
my girl lets me wear her i kiss all skin
t-shirt it's comfy
uh let me know if you want to i kissed
on skin t-shirt your ecuadorian friend
is hot i don't know who the [ __ ] my
ecuadorian friend is ecuador i don't
know
when you upgrade do you want a house or
an rv
i don't know
do you have any advice for a college
student waiting wanting to do stand-up
my advice is start a stand-up thing in
your college college students are some
of the best audiences they're [ __ ]
uh really really nice and kind and you
know they're young and their minds are
fresh and flexible
um and uh you have like a fan invited me
to the thanksgiving dinner
like in the beginning of november and i
went
and i met their whole family they lived
in like a rich part of austin
and i ate all their food i played vr
with them
i uh i just hung out with them it's
pretty cool
um do you cook a lot in your van or eat
out a lot i cook a lot of my van i have
food stamps from new york state i get
200 bucks a month i think that stopped
though and i'm fine with it because i
have a lot of money now but i have like
800 dollars banked up on food stamps so
i uh go to the grocery store and i buy
like
meat and then i have like a hot plate in
here and i cook in there
there's a crackhead outside your van
i mean this is a pretty
good neighborhood
it's like an nyc apartment yeah
van life
are you sponsored by gatorade
nope
i don't know why this is like so
but before you can see bernie's head
over there
but yeah i was sponsored by joe uh
bernie sanders
snap i call snap food stamps just so
people know what i'm talking about
i don't see ebt or snap because most
people aren't up to date on america's
social welfare system
i want to normalize food stamps i think
it's good for comedians uh that way they
don't starve to death
don't turn on the black light in that
thing sheesh
i do masturbate a lot in here i mean
living in a van you want to be well
masturbated or you're going to be a
crazy horned up van dweller
but i'm usually pretty good about
cleaning up i have a system
i have a good system going
to clean up my
semen so you don't have to worry about
that you can blacklight me all you want
how long you think one two years for the
netflix special probably like five
what i want to do is i want to tour the
country doing an hour over a long period
of time
um
and i want to get an hour
down pat i want to get really good at
doing an hour
everyone should be able to eat yes
communism exists you just have to reach
out and take it they have a lot of means
testing but
we can have food stamps at least for the
most part
[Music]
sir
france
french
can you
sir french sir excuse me sir french can
you
can you speak french
i always start gag
whenever i speak french
five years there might not be a netflix
yeah i mean it's so crazy because when i
was a wee lad
the only thing that was on was comedy
central and everyone was like oh i want
an hbo comedy comedy central now comedy
central specials aren't even a thing no
one aspires to that anymore so it's like
the landscape is always changing so my
dream isn't in a corporation or a
uh
empty token or like a trophy my
aspiration is to be the voice of the
people and how the people love me for
telling them poop jokes
uh
so yeah i mean uh i don't i don't aspire
for a company i aspire for uh career
success and uh competence in my chosen
career
um spanish
have you watched the chose show
no
[Music]
how's kalila been
and rudy i'm not bobby lee
why do you think following tony is the
best for your career aren't the best
comedians one who built their careers by
themselves who is a comedian who built a
career by themselves who has not been
helped by comedy clubs and other
comedians
and
random homeless people and their mothers
and fathers and the roads that were
built for them and the uh electricity
that was uh was funded by taxpayers
money
um
i say no man is an island and we are all
reliant on the society we live in let's
make sure that society is a good one
that helps foster people instead of
hurts them
and uses them as cheap labor to make
money for billionaires judd apate
get a good hour down throw it on youtube
then your next hour someone will
definitely buy it yeah
that's
my next hour
boom just put an hour on netflix on
youtube then another hour someone will
buy
yeah that's if only it was easier said
than none how about german
yeah
spreckens
shirley algon
uh that's all i know i don't know a lot
of profession in german i'm barely
proficient in french i'm not proficient
at all in french i can speak spanish a
little bit but you gotta talk slow and
i have an accent obviously hans we're
shooting a film in austin early next
year i have a part for you you in
depends on how much work i have to do
and how early i have to show up if it's
at 2 pm and i'm only there for 3 minutes
i'm fine with that also if it's like
right next to open mics
then i'll definitely do
it comes can i send you food yes please
you're awesome on fresh just instagram
message me until it's time but enough or
is a good place meet foreign asian girls
straight from the source like online
it's it possible
foreign asian girls well first of all
have a personality that foreign asian
girls would like and then take to the
[ __ ] internet and start chatting up
random people
uh
if
friend
schlub can get a special you for sure
can get one i mean people like to [ __ ]
on and beat up brennan schaub
and i think it's uh
funny
but uh he's a very tough guy and he can
take it but i think uh it's a little a
little little bullying a little mean
uh people want to uh
people want to be mean to brendan shop
he just looks like he can take it he's
like so big and fluffy you just want to
poke at him like
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
um but he's i'm he's a very nice guy i'm
sure
and i think
he has a very tough road to hoe and i
don't envy him but i think that he can
do it and i would love to see him in the
future
prove all the haters wrong
best open mic shows in austin
the best open mic shows in austin
maybe the buzz mill
on tuesdays
outdoor it's pretty cool
creek in the cave always has dope open
mics
uh it's so grimy in the creek it's just
like the lowest [ __ ] the worst mood
it's like we're barely doing comedy but
it's like [ __ ] real it's raw man it's
so hard it's the hardest place to do
open mics but it's the place i love the
most
he's a very nice guy doesn't mean he's
funny though no but i think you can
learn how to be funny i think it's
pretty easy
i think that you can do it
um
have you seen brendan schaub's asian
doctor
well if brandon shaw was gonna do an
asian doctor impression which i imagine
sounds like this oh
you coming to my doctor office oh you
have very very big ball no so sad you're
so big and so stupid
then i can do a bread and shove
impression
[Music]
i think you're wrong
so fun i'm so funny my mom made my
password
where the hell is that hans at the open
mics i go out every night i hit the mics
i say hey to the girls and they hurl
because i'm gross
hans kim is [ __ ] blood right now
mark norman
oh it's an honor to be uh implicated in
blood [ __ ] by one of the best
comedians in the world mark norman what
a great great uh
funny thing that happened in my life
touch my camera through the fence and
how many accidents can you say touch my
camera through the fence and
uh where is tiger when is tiger blake
coming to australia why are you
asking me it's not like all koreans have
a connection
this is korean talk time
have you met tom segura yes he was in
the green room he had like a little cast
on
uh he was opening for joe rogan as was i
and i opened up and at the creek in the
cave and it was [ __ ] dope because
creek in the cave is uh
greg of the cave is like where all the
comedians
hang out
so it's cool to um do
open up for joe rogan there and have
everyone see me open up for joe rogan
there it's like
my friends got to see me open up for joe
rogan there like the vulcan i open up
for joe rogan all the time but it's for
strangers and people who don't care
about me but
these people who are jealous of me and
who are trying to do better than me they
saw me achieve
the pinnacle of
my career and i'm glad that they they
were forced to sit there and watch me do
it
uh no it was not a negative thing it was
a positive thing like i got to
go up on a stage where i do open mics at
and open for one of the biggest
comedians in the world and it was just
such a
such an honor to be at home and yet
doing something so crazy
are you live streaming on multiple sites
i'm live streaming on instagram.com and
also youtube.com i want to diversify my
portfolio so that if youtube bans me
or if
um you know instagram
bands me then i have this other thing i
really hope that i don't get demonetized
for saying the c word
someone baited me into saying it by
telling me i couldn't say it
but uh i think that's ridiculous because
it's a good word
i'm from east korea
um
so yeah uh
does your van have wi-fi i'm in front of
my buddy riley's house and his house has
wi-fi so i'm just borrowing that
the geek in the cave
um
why do you look depressed
because i don't have to artificially
make myself feel happy to feel good
about myself i'm miserable all the time
and i'm happier than most people
do you eat dog
i don't eat dog i only eat normal human
food um i would eat dog though if it was
good or first cooked well so you're not
coming up in may coming up where in may
has rogers invited you to sauna and cryo
yet
no
i
okay there's a lot of things i want from
joe rogan but i'm not gonna ask him for
any of it i'm gonna just play it cool
and take whatever little
giblets and goblets fall from his dinner
table
i'm like a dog i'm just going to catch
it in my mouth whenever it whenever it
deems me worthy enough
hook me up with christina mariani okay
what makes you think that you deserve or
could handle christina mariani
christina mariani is a very beautiful
very uh
talented stand-up comedian she writes
amazing jokes
and she is uh very funny and very hot to
a lot of people
and i think that uh you just gotta bide
your time and prove to her that you're
there for her and
reliable the mere exposure effect might
help and also that you're a nice person
and you can hang and that you're good in
bed and if you can do all that maybe you
can get with christina mariani but
did you see sven's joe animation no
please come up where in may where do
people want me in may
how much do you make per year very very
little i live in a van
uh if i was making 50k i probably
wouldn't be in a van i'd probably be in
a home or something
think of how many b holes have been
stretched in that van
okay
that's
not that many buttholes
maybe one or two my butthole and others
how do you feel about the mythbusters
guy dying well as a nerd mythbusters is
like my
pinnacle
of uh achievement
um
mythbusters is like such a great show
for nerds it's like nerds being nerds
and like making a contribution to
society and not just being losers so the
mythbusters guy dying is pretty sad can
i beat up bobby lee i heard he used to
wrestle
i mean i think i'm heavier than him and
taller than him so maybe i could get him
in a like a triangle or like an arm bar
like
a kimura or americana or something but i
think that
bobby lee is used to success and
successful people don't like to lose and
so he's going to have this extra umph
and motivation to him
that
i wouldn't want to tangle with so i
think my best option for defeating bobby
lee is to not fight him at all um
uh i'm just gonna play nice and just try
to be
his friend and then maybe you can defeat
an enemy by making him a friend
uh so yes i don't want to fight bobby
lee i think that he would get on top of
me like a rock and then i wouldn't be
able to get up because he has very high
density
i don't have anything to say but really
thanks man
thanks for listening to me
um
what's your go-to submission in bidge
um my go-to is probably guillotine but i
really like the idea of a triangle
um
now that you kissed half of texas women
could you give us some tips
yes
here's kissing tips with hans kim
so when you kiss a girl the first thing
you want to do
is get a good hug in you want to wrap
around and just like that's that's a
large part of the kiss is like close
physical contact and rubbing your
genitals onto her legs or stomach
and her
mushing her vagina onto your legs or
stomach
um
the thing about uh kissing is that you
just have to feel it out and
see what the other person is into and
just like
i like to think about it like i'm
tasting her like try to taste the person
see what they're all about it's like a
dog sniffing buttholes you're just like
getting a good sampling of what their
microbiome is like and if you think
they're disgusting you probably
shouldn't be kissing her but if you
really want to know what they're all
about just start tasting away just
just get it all over your mouth and see
what what kind of flavor they are and
just really get it all over your mouth
i like to think of when i'm kissing a
girl that her dad is watching and then
doing things that her dad would
disapprove of be like look at me i'm
tasting your daughter i'm doing things
to your daughter that is just so wrong
and then her dad would be like oh my god
look at what you're doing you horrible
[ __ ]
and then that's like probably the right
thing to do if it's like if it's going
to make her dad sad then do that
that's just how i kiss
when you start touring will you come to
chicago the third biggest city in
america
na i think i'll just skip over one of
the
most amazing american cities
i'll just [ __ ] go to winosha or
pattoti or tikala boots in wisconsin
of course i'll go to chicago if i can do
you think the old comedic advice of
having you to stand up for 10 years when
you become a good comic or do you think
there's other catalysts
i mean shane gillis has only been doing
comedy eight years or something when he
got snl so i think there's definitely
ways you can
get
faster
um
no he says he won't be coming up in may
guys he's too stingy where am i going in
may i've missed it people want me to go
somewhere in may so i guess if i don't
go i'm an [ __ ]
does rogan work for the caa
joe rogan is a national hero do not
insult mr rogan
okay the thing about joe rogan is that i
don't agree with everything he says
but he is our best hope against
corporate interest politicians don't
give a [ __ ] about us joe rogan does he
speaks for the people he will fight for
us if exxon valdez went and [ __ ]
polluted lady bird lake in austin right
now joe rogan would [ __ ] talk about
it on his podcast with millions of
viewers he would shame exxon valdez
and
[ __ ] would happen
um
[ __ ] you know like he is he he is the
voice of the people he's one of the
people that got a large platform and
he's not beholden to any powers like
politicians or [ __ ]
other people are
you know he is our best hope he is our
our white knight to save us if the
corporations ever start [ __ ] with
people he can stand up to exxon valdez
and
exxon mobil
and
enron and you know
price proctor gamble like he doesn't
give a [ __ ] if they do something [ __ ]
up he's gonna talk about it and shame
them so he is
he is a voice of the people he will
fight for us and i trust that he will
even if he does it incorrectly he thinks
he's doing the right thing and he thinks
he's helping people and that's not
something that
a lot of people
are
gonna do for us
he is he is for the people and i believe
in him and i support him a hundred
percent hans wants to kiss joe rogan
next
i mean
honestly like that's the least of what i
would willing to do for joe rogan so if
he asked me to i will definitely make
out with joe rogan
and he tell any regulars you think are
un
undeserved undeserving what the [ __ ]
this is why you're not a kill tony
regularis because you're trying to find
people who are undeserving have a more
positive outlook
i know joe rogan is like sort of like
saying a lot of things that people
there don't uh support but like you
can't deny his motivations and his
purpose is to help people and he is um
he's there for us
as everyone you cried after the show
tony almost hit tossed me
and i kind of liked it because it felt
like he would only do that to someone he
cared about rogan don't care about
anything unless it's in the way of his
archery target
touch my camera through the fence
i don't understand this a lot of this
i don't understand like someone was like
shout out to gripers and i was like i
just read it and then it was like oh
gropers are actually like racist white
people who hate mexicans or something
is the guy in the wheelchair prop comic
uh hip toss or [ __ ] toss
he would just wrestle him down to kiss
hans i want to laugh
okay dalton checkos uh
you know
is red band as long as he comes across
red band is so so nice he's the nicest
guy ever what are you doing
for us deadbeat slobs
i'm not doing anything for you guys
besides live
thank you
uh
i just got booked to do the secret show
on friday so please come out see me
hopefully it focuses
best dad joke team everywhere team jacob
how should i drink tonight i don't like
drinking
i'd rather do drugs
where are the bodies can you talk about
the side effects of the chinese vaccine
feels amazing man the side effects of
the chinese vaccine is that you love the
ccp
and you
support death camps for uyghurs
and you hate
things
that chinese people are supposed to hate
what's the average pay for kill tony i
feel like i'm looking out of hansa's
eyes
that's kind of racist
i see fine i mean i don't have the best
vision
huh but which drugs there are so many
i like mushrooms right now
uh weed is always good are you still in
the blue van i saw university housing
nope top three former kale tony regulars
um
all of them are really good how long
does it take you to write a minute for
kill tony a whole week
of resting and sleeping and farting and
masturbating that's how i do kill tony
with minutes
have you tried moose soup reading any
good books
we're reading a lot of big books about
communism
pro-communism did you kiss christy yet
no chrissy won't kiss me kristy doesn't
like me like that she thinks i'm gross
and
she's just like
ugh
i just like you for your career
ambitions and
your conversation
i don't understand that like if you like
someone why not let them make you orgasm
like you can only take orgasms from
people who make you feel a certain way
it's like take orgasms wherever you can
get it what's the best streams you've
taken and have you had a bad trip
and i've got beat up by the cops once
what are your thoughts on the uyghurs
i think they're
dope people
maybe they dance a little funny
and their hats are stupid but you know
you shouldn't put them in concentration
camps you should probably let them live
their lives
in [ __ ] west china who gives a [ __ ]
you want all of china to be chinese
that's so [ __ ] selfish
it's better to be diversified it's
better to have different cultures these
[ __ ] chinese people don't understand
the value of diversity they just want
everyone to be like them because they're
a [ __ ] hive mind
i went to starbucks and said my name was
ching chong bing mong
and they wouldn't make my drink any
advice i'm also not asian at all yeah if
you're not asian that's like really
racist
so maybe step number one be asian
hans would you ever date your mom
haha i agree
um i think chris kaley funk has too much
attitude for hans
i mean she's a very confident american
woman and uh i'm into that you know i
like being told what to do too i don't
always have to like boss a woman around
and make them make me tea
hanza is a chinese spy if i was a
chinese spy why would i support the
uyghurs
that's just ridiculous
i definitely don't do not support china
i think that they're backwards in a lot
of ways and if they got their [ __ ]
together if they were a legit
alternative to america like things could
be so much better but they're not
they're just too myopic and focused on
their own little [ __ ] dumb country
it's like have have larger aspirations
this is why you lost the [ __ ]
uh boxer rebellion and [ __ ]
and whatever war
that burton got hong kong in
it's because you are lost
you you're just too focused on
yourselves or whatever
um
i think it's great that uh
china exists
and maybe we should have more china's
all over the place
um
would you do euro comedy with your van
yeah i hear they love tennis in china
always because that woman got
disappeared from china
um
[Music]
so
you guys want to watch like a crazy
video or something
um
so you guys think it's weird that uh
is america a racist country
in some ways yes some ways no because
america has so many different people and
it's just easier to be racist here but
most countries are racist they just
don't have other people to yell at right
in america we uh we can yell at each
other all the time
and then it's like we do
but we also have structural racism where
like black people are [ __ ]
uh chinese spy says
what i mean honestly
if i was a chinese spy
i would be doing a better job at it i
wouldn't be so out in the open either
it's like a very public place
uh look at how bad the natives were to
each other
i mean they were bad but
i think
white people were the best
you know take some credit white people
you're really good at being bad to other
races it's like other people are good at
it yes and they do horrible things but
not at the scale and breadth that white
people do it and it's just impressive
honestly it's not even i'm not even
shaming you guys
it's like
other people wish they were as racist as
you are you're the best at being racist
all these other races are being racist
in like an ineffective way when
americans are racist
it's like [ __ ] awesome
it's like they actually have a benefit
they get richer
like chinese people are racist and it
does nothing
they're just racist and they put uyghurs
in camps
that does nothing for them it doesn't
make them any money white people are
racist they [ __ ] own congo now they
get all the rubber they get all the
coffee from you know it's like their
racism is so much more effective and
more impactful
uh starved asian says hello
say hello
yeah it's sad that china is shitty
biggest butcher in history oh please
genghis khan has nothing on [ __ ]
europe
genghis khan wishes he could have killed
as many people as europeans did over a
long period of time
yeah japanese people were terrible
but they weren't good at it because they
got defeated by america
i mean just like the length of time
ameri white people have been colonizing
i just i just respect it you know you
gotta give respect where respect is due
they've been [ __ ] up [ __ ] for a long
time
uh will the real racists please stand up
yeah i'm pretty racist
um
we haven't evolved enough though yet we
will grow out of this dumb phase we are
just stupid and that's all it takes is
uh has top three all-time high they made
pyramids with skulls
yeah genghis khan was pretty bad but
like
the
[ __ ] uh
industrial way without we do it without
any moral implications and just like
moral responsibilities it's like pretty
impressive
how was working on the railroad do they
really treat you guys as bad as they say
i heard it was pretty bad
um
i mean
think about like
south america and africa
and southeast asia
those are whole continents with a lot
more people than during genghis khan's
time
because this is literally all the women
which asian country has the hottest
women i would say japanese
uh
second korean third chinese but really
it's all subjective because i don't
really consume chinese media i don't
really get to see chinese hot girls
um
i don't know what to do do you play
video games yes i play starcraft
why don't i just play starcraft
that seems fun i'll probably have to
download a bunch of updates because i
haven't played in forever
but uh is it true that korean japanese
are running the show business in japan
japanese guys with korean roots probably
not i think koreans don't like japanese
people that much
and that if there is a japanese spy they
would execute him somebody once told me
the world is going to roll
me ain't the sharpest tool on the shirt
she was looking kind of dumb with her
finger and her thumb with the shape of a
little forehead
you comparing one asian dude to all of
europe come on hans i'm comparing all of
asia to all of europe
i think uh
europe dominated
i'm saying you guys are good
and dominating like why is that such a
bad thing how much does it cost to live
in a van pretty pretty cheap
i think vietnamese vietnam and the
philippines are the hottest asian oh
yeah southeast asians are hot
there's enough hot asians for all of us
do people on the street just hear you
talking to
i don't think so it's pretty insulated
hello can anyone hear me out there
please tell me
tell me if you can hear me
this is where i'm at right now
it's too bright
why is hinge all overweight women
update
so i do i do love white people
um i've lived within white white land
for about 32 years so this is my home
and white people have created the only
multicultural country
in the world nothing else exists like
america
although they were the only ones that
were in a position to do it and they
were kind of trapped by their
constitution or like what they thought
this country was how often do you wash
your hands
uh
the word he means is advanced do you
play tekken can we get a tour of the van
yes there's an echo in here i have asian
close enough we need a roast battle
between hans and david lucas i'm very
afraid of that i feel like david lucas
is really good at roasting and i have a
lot to be roasted for
uh david lucas is very very proficient
and he would see things in me that i
don't know if i uh
want to be seen
um
do i think southeast asian people are
hot yes they're hot as [ __ ] they're
brown
but i just feel like their [ __ ] are a
weird color
i think japanese women are the hottest
because
um
i think japanese people are the hottest
because uh
no no they're just skinny and
they got bigger eyes and their faces are
normal shaped they haven't been [ __ ]
by the mongols i think is a big thing i
think korean people have a lot of mongol
blood in them and same with chinese
people so they're like this weird hybrid
big faces and
and skinny bodies
mongols are supposed to be squat so they
can ride horses
um but i think koreans and chinese
people have too much fat
fat mongol face going on to be hot
and japanese women are like small and
like
i think they're the hottest
uh
i'm getting more racist as the podcast
goes on
something that would surprise us about
kill tony
um something that you you guys might be
surprised about
about kill tony
is that the comedians all stand in the
pen i guess you guys all know that white
women are the hottest let's be real
incorrect latinas are the hottest which
are a combination of aztecs and white
people
so i guess you guys take some of the
credit
but i do think latinas are the most
beautiful they have beautiful eyes and
beautiful skin and beautiful body types
mongolian
jeans uh what do you think of roy
scoville i think he's great he's not
like my type of comedy but i think he's
great regardless and he's like good at
improv and he's sort of from seattle so
i love him
free drinks for regulars
uh most surprising thing about kill tony
is probably how much fun it is how crazy
the energy is and how like most people
will never get to experience it live and
how great the energy in that room is
why not
so i'm uh turning on starcraft 2 right
now
and you're the [ __ ] man thank you
latinas are too loud and demanding i
like hot submissive white women
yeah white women are submissive if you
think white women are submissive wait
till you see asian women have you done
comedy at nyc yeah i've done a little
comedy in nyc i did comedy in for three
years in the open mics never got the
respect that i thought i deserved maybe
i didn't deserve it but
you know
i was in new york slumming it away with
all you [ __ ] hood rats
and i thought new york was an amazing
city i just think that it's too
corrupt and entrenched power rules there
and i don't want to kiss ass and that's
what a lot of new york is is like
kissing ass so that you can get into the
big infrastructure
clubs that are set up i think julius and
mark norman would like you i hope so
they're so cool
asian women are best yeah asian women
are best if you don't like asses or tits
um they have very beautiful faces and
they're all skinny the thing about asian
women is that they all look
like a hot girl they have the shape of a
hot girl and then you look at them and
then they're like
they're all
busted in different ways
okay so i turned on starcraft
so i'm gonna play a game of 1v1
and hopefully no one stream snipes me
let me uh reduce reuse recycle
audio video capture device
i just got booked on two shows
i think
yeah
so i just got booked on the filthy show
come on saturday
uh
to the creek in the cave
oh god how the [ __ ] do i
make this smaller
uh-oh
what's happening
oh that's weird
i don't know how to make it
smaller i'm trying to make it smaller so
i can play starcraft but i can't do it
how much you tip for truck water stop
wanks truck truck stop winks
i bought a hooker once for 250 dollars
are you high no
um i went to a massage parlor
in seattle and i got
to have sex with a hooker
i don't think it was worth it
and being said i said i'm meeting up
with
wasn't going to fit a desk in here yeah
you can fit a lot of things in here this
is how desks get transported is their
trucks
there we go
okay
i don't know what's going on
i don't know how to
do this
audio display capture
pretty new sure
okay
and then how do i
make the
thing come up
okay
it's taking a while
um
hans how often are you getting up right
now i got up six times yesterday so you
could say i'm on top of my game
uh display oh no video capture
video capture
that existing
that buzzing is really annoying
uh
i hope i'm not reviewing anything open
your eyes brb gonna hack hans kim holy
[ __ ] all in awesome
austin
cool do you ever do spots at the
velveeta room yeah i did a spot there
long time ago and then i want to go
there again
the veto room is good i want to do
headlining spots there soon i hope that
you guys will come out i can sell it out
i'm about to play starcraft 2. i only
play starcraft 2.
i'm trying to
get the video so you guys can watch my
face as i play
how do i do this
is hanza dj i'm not a dj i just chose
that name because
i think djs are like kind of ridiculous
so it's like i don't mind stealing their
valor
i think most djs are a little stupid
um
hopefully this will work
so
on bing chilling i love dj dad and mouth
whole foods oh whole foods folder is
like a sketch that we did with my friend
you want to watch the whole foods
sketch
it's pretty stupid
but i'm willing to be stupid on stream
oh my god why is it not working
this is my former friend ange all right
go
these glasses aren't like prescription
per se but
they still make me see the world clear
okay see the logo
no
yeah
gigs of whole foods yeah maybe i should
delete it
i'm still trying to find out how to get
my video to show up
um
so the van life is pretty cool
i love van life
um
i do a lot of
cool things on the van
okay
here we go
boom
okay make this smaller
let's make it a little bit smaller
like how the
professional stream
and let's turn it around
to face me
and now i'm gaming
display capture
wow i don't know how i did that
hopefully my computer doesn't explode
but i'm going to play 1v1
uh let's turn this around
show this
and now i'm playing starcraft 2 on igtv
and
youtube
so that's kind of cool
uh hans why don't you go out there
slaying puss
because it's a very fruitless endeavor
i really don't like going out there to
talk to people that i don't really care
about trying to get them to suck my dick
i think it's like very very
soul-crushing and it's like why am i
doing something that i don't want to do
um i don't like doing that i would
rather just like do whatever i want to
do because girls are everywhere so let
me just do whatever the [ __ ] i want to
do there's going to be a girl there and
then hopefully i'm not a creep and
hopefully i can [ __ ] him but it's not
like i'm just going to go to 6th street
and like be one of those idiots
and like all the girls are like we're
not here to meet boys but they're there
to meet boys all the dudes are like i'm
kind of here to [ __ ] and at least
they're honest about it but it's like so
stupid i i think it's like not a good
thing to do
i think people just do it because
they're horny as [ __ ] or they think that
they're supposed to
any girls out there on starcraft that
want to make out with hans
definitely there's a lot of girls
who are play starcraft oh what the [ __ ]
happened
i think my internet's too slow
it's not working
your status has been locked
what does that mean
it's not working i did all this work and
it's not working
you're not alone brother or sad um i
mean i ideally we would be able to go
out and [ __ ]
[ __ ] other people
okay i'm gonna play two on two because i
can't play one-on-one for some reason
even though i totally would because i'm
not a [ __ ]
uh
what the [ __ ]
why is my status locked
anyone know what's going on
i don't think it's gonna work
i might just play tetris or something
so yeah i mean life is pretty good i'm
opening up for joe rogan two weeks ago
hasn't happened again but
you know i'm still riding that high of
opening up for my
favorite comedian and the reason why i
got started into comedy
um i enjoy just talking or being in the
green room with him like i just sit
there and listen hopefully i don't talk
too much i mean anytime i talk too much
in the green room with joe rogan oh i
shouldn't do this
anytime i talk too much in the room with
joe rogan it's like
uh what brought you to monster kid in
winston-salem i don't think i was there
i went to cider cade
in
dallas
with this old woman
so
i'll let me tell you guys a little story
a weeded story about me
in
this place
called dallas
i met a woman at a show who was old she
was like 43
and
i got her number and then later she was
like hey uh
i want to come to a show again and so i
was like sure okay let's come to a show
and i told her what show to come to and
then
she came to the show and
it was like
really awesome
and then she was like all negative the
whole time she was like really old she
said she had two strokes
uh
she was like really negative and really
[ __ ] she's like oh my god this place
sucks the vibes are awful let's go to
cider cage
then we went there and then we played
like two games and then we left and then
she was like i'm not giving a ride back
i was like the only reason i came out is
because you said you gave me a ride home
she's like i'm not doing it i'm getting
really anxious right now so i'm just
gonna go
i was like you're a [ __ ]
i called her a [ __ ]
and then she left
but yeah i mean it's just like don't uh
say you're gonna do something and then
don't do it especially like a ride and
then i had to pay 50 for a lift which
isn't too bad but i don't want to spend
50 dollars to talk to an old person
uh do you play chess no that's going to
be on the podcast what's it like talking
to rogan i do play chess um
chess is fun
i enjoy playing chess
uh i don't play it a lot though i only
play with people who don't know the
opening moves and who are just bad like
me because then it's not so unfun but
it's fun because chess you're like oh if
i move there then they'll do that but if
i move there then that and it's just
like that over and over again so it's
just like
and you get to beat someone
intellectually like if you want to feel
that feeling of just like owning someone
then yeah chess is a great game uh
what's it like talking to joe rogan
talking to joe rogan is like being on
his podcast and i get to talk about the
same amount
um
donald rogan is like he's a train he's
just like the most powerful energy i've
ever felt and he just takes over a
conversation and it's not like an
annoying take over the conversation you
want him to take over the conversation
because he's so interesting and
captivating and he's like the most
successful person in the room so you
want him to talk a lot you don't want to
hear what [ __ ] you know
the water boy has to say or his openers
like who gives a [ __ ] let me just listen
to rogan talk so he talks a lot and
people let him and he wants to and we
want to listen to him it's like an
energy that i've never felt before it's
like earned meritocracy it's like earned
attention
and uh it's one of the privileges of my
life to be able to hang out and listen
and talk with joe rogan
um
so yeah
my life is pretty dope
because i get to be [ __ ] to
people that i want to be [ __ ] too
um
flip this around
i have no idea what my youtube viewers
are like
uh
i like youtube better instagram i don't
get as many viewers on youtube i get
more viewers on you play every move your
friend takes and do whatever the
computer does you win every time
there's this like uh darren brown on
youtube you should check him out he
plays 17
or 30 grand masters
and what he does is like
he memorizes what moves each person
makes so if like one guy moves over here
then he does the same thing over here
and so they're basically just playing
each other but he makes it look like
he's playing them
and so he defeats half of them he loses
to half of them and then the
grandmasters are like wow it was like
feeling like i was playing with another
grand master well you were you were
playing with that guy over there he was
just the intermediary making the moves
so that's a pretty cool trick
uh sounds like a call
um i mean everything sounds like a call
ideally you would be in an awesome cult
i would love to be in a brothers and
cursive reboot well it was fun trying to
play starcraft hopefully it'll work
but i think that's the end of my stream
thank you guys so much for listening and
being here i love you so much
and good night love you